good evening members officers and
welcome to this full council meeting
today thursday the 2nd of september
2021 i am councillor mark hurd chairman
of morden district council
as you know members the set up for this
meeting has been designed to mitigate
for covid
therefore in the interests of member and
officer safety i ask all present to work
to the protocols agreed at council on
the 29th of april
2021
we are streaming this meeting live so
good evening those members of the public
who are watching this meeting is being
recorded so be by being present at the
meeting you are giving your consent to
be recorded
members during each item please put your
hand up to indicate you wish to speak
and i would invite you at the
appropriate time
when invited to speak please wait for
the roving microphone to come to you and
speak clearly
if you reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers that will help all concerned and
please remain seated when speaking
so please remember members
please wait for the microphone to come
to you
so that everyone can hear you and the
members of the public can hear you on
the live feed
i will draw your attention to the
supplementary pack for items 11
and 16 a
i'm going to move on now to agenda item
number two which is apologies for
absence tara do we have the apologies
please
[Music]
thank you very much indeed um i do
happen to know uh members that uh
councillor beale is currently in
hospital and i'm sure we all wish him
well
agenda item three this is to disclose
the existence and nature of any
disclosed disclosable pecuniary
interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraphs six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded
that they are also required to disclose
such interests as soon as they become
aware should the need arise throughout
the meetings do i have any declarations
please counsellor
durham i just hold you there a second
we'll just wait for the roving mike to
come to you thank you maisie
thank you chairman
that's a member of essex county council
thank you
thank you very much do i have any other
declarations
casa stamp
i don't know you've got a microphone
there have you here we are amazing over
here
that's it thanks
yes thank you chairman just i'm a member
of essex county council uh
thank you very much indeed
okay no other declarations
we'll move on to agenda item four
council minutes from the 30th of june
2021 it is recommended that the minutes
of the meeting held on that date found
on pages 5 to 18
are approved as a true and accurate
record these are presented for accuracy
only
i so move
do i have a secondary
councillor maze thank you
if any member wishes to raise any matter
of accuracy they need to indicate their
wish to speak
counselor channel oh cancer thompson i'm
sorry
oh i did see yes it is yeah counselor
channel
thank you
thank you um chairman i think i did send
an email to you
guys with me chairman um
regarding actually minute 131 which is
on pages actually it covers pages nine
to ten
chairman can i just say firstly i'll try
to keep this short i think it's a great
pity that many points raised by certain
councillors swain white stilts hubner
and civil and thompson were not perhaps
referred to directly i know that minutes
aren't verbatim of a record but perhaps
sometimes you reflect the individual
counsellors
i do feel chairman however there is a
very pertinent question that was asked i
know the minutes under the four bullet
points to answers given
however there was a pertinent question
regarding something which all members
have a great interest in and was asked
by councillor thompson and very clear
definitive response given by the
director of strategy performance and
governance the response is not recorded
in the answers to questions mrs thompson
asked a very direct important question
regarding
will this body meaning one more than be
taking over the direct discussions that
mdc have had with the department of
health or the nhs about the health hub
or community hospital and then she
continued with other things the director
of strategy performance and governance
gave a direct clear answer along the
lines of
wood not meaning the one malden replaced
direct discussions with the nhs around
the health hub so those would continue
through the modern operational group as
they do now which we are directly
representing which we are directly
presented on where's that effect
chairman i do think we ought to have a
fifth bullet point um reflecting that
answer given um there's four bullet
points already showing answers in
response to questions asked but i think
that's a very important pertinent
question that was asked by council mrs
thompson and i think the very direct
clear answer from the director of
strategy performance and governance
should be recorded thank you chairman
that's the matter of accuracy um it's on
a mission really thank you
thank you councillor channel our members
happy for that fifth bullet point to be
inserted
agreed okay counselor mrs thompson did
you wish to speak
okay
that's noted thank you very much
so we'll have those
amended
i think they can come back at the next
meeting am i correct
they are yes good thank you very much
uh agenda item five public questions we
now move to to that uh as notified by
members of the public
i have not received any
i moved to
chairman's announcements
i have i'm very grateful to vice
chairman councillor mays who has
represented me on
two occasions uh one of them was uh
dagenham i believe and the other was
romford was it
south end i beg your pardon so i'm very
grateful for her stepping in for me
thank you very much indeed
agenda item 7 is the minute book
and
i will call on councillor richard sidle
chairman of the strategy resources
committee to present the minutes
councillor siddall
uh chairman i present the minutes of the
strategy and resources committee meeting
held remote held on the 15th of july 21
it wasn't remote
founded on pages 19 to 36
and i propose their reception and
adoption
uh with the exception which i'll come to
to minutes numbers 160 and 163
uh i have been notified by councillor
boyce
that he would like to raise a
a a question
on minute number one six six
and i think we might have to close the
meeting to do so
confidential
yes i i believe this was a confidential
matter council civil that's correct so
if councillor voice does have a question
on minute 166
we will have to close the meeting
councillor councillor boyce
just um three over to the left thank you
thank you chairman um and uh councillor
i do have a question uh regarding
land values and as this subject was
taken
in
private and confidential
i ask you if you want me to ask this in
public now or
uh to and until we go into pmc
at the end of the meeting
i think it will assist us if we uh if we
stay open until then and then we can re
come back to that matter then
thank you thank you very much council
voice
and back to councillor sidle again thank
you
uh so uh with the the exception of 166
um at the the
minute 160
uh recommended that the council ratifies
the response
to the highways england public
consultation
for the preliminary design of the a12 to
a120 widening scheme s as set out in
appendix one to these minutes can i have
a to please
councillor swain i see thank you thank
you can we agree that minute by our
ascent members
i then moved to minute 163
the advice service contract
and i put forward the recommendation
that bidder 1 be awarded the contract
for delivering an advice service from
october 2021 can i have a second to
please
councillor mays
council amazed uh
can we agree this via ascent members
i so moved apart from obviously minute
166 which we will come back to
at the closed session thank you chairman
thank you very much councillor siddall
i now move to performance governance and
audit committee
i call on councillor mrs jeannette
stiltz chairman of performance
governance in audit to present the
minutes
councillor mrs stilts
[Music]
government
on the
29th of july 2021. these are for noting
only um can i ask that these are found
on pages 37 to 41. 42 is blank
i so moved can i have a second please
councillor mays
thank you mr chairman
can we agree those by can we note those
members
thank you very much
we now move on to the joint standards
committee and i call on councillor mark
massinger to uh chairman of joint
standards committee to present the
minutes council of bassinger
thank you chairman chairman i present
the minutes of the joint standards
committee held on the 17th of august
2021
found on pages 43-50 and i propose their
reception and adoption
do i have a seconder
councillor maze
councilmance
i draw your attention to page 44 minute
214 consultation on complaints process
and amendments to the articles for
standards
arrangements together with the
recommendation to the council on page 45
iso move
thank you can we agree those by sent
members
agreed i have a councillor channel
i've also noted councillor swain as well
so councillor channel first
um
thank you very much
um regarding the recommendation that
council of battlegrounds doesn't move
um
i did listen to that meeting um and can
i just say actually i felt that
councilman
um gave very very good
thoughts and thinking and made very
sensible suggestions
i thought actually he was exceptionally
fair
and particularly
actually any group leader should be
notified confidentially
when perhaps there was a complaint in
respect to one of the members that might
be in their group i understand why the
leader might but i do think councillor
civil um was
actually
uh
that actually um confidentially the
group leaders should be notified of a
trump late regarding one of the urgent
members and that's where i was going to
move rather
than
um
okay um can we just go to i understand
that thank you can we just hear
councillor swain what you have to say
please counselor swain
uh yes thank you uh
chairman a couple of points one on um
page 47 where we're
dealing with um uh the parish council um
representation
on jsc
um and the fallback to
appoint the appointments by the town
council and burningtown
to the two town councils um
this reflects uh to some extent the
difficulty in getting
an adequate process for the parish
council representatives um but if um if
they if they do come forward i think
they should serve for more than the two
years two years is hardly going to give
anybody much experience of the jsc they
may perhaps only have one meeting so i i
think that should be a longer term
and the other point is on page
49 where um
group leaders are
are to be involved or could be involved
in informal arrangements i i disagree
with the involvement of group leaders at
all
in any
of the complaints process
just over on the right hand side thank
you
yeah thank you chairman chairman um and
i speak in support of councillor chana's
point
i think it's absolutely essential that
the group leaders are informed when a
complaint is made against somebody in
their group they don't need to be given
the specific details of the complaint
but i believe that once a complaint has
been established as not being
vexatious or repetitive by the
independent person in the mo
the group leader should be notified that
that there is an ongoing complaint
um
also chairman in respect of uh
councillor swain's point about a parish
representative
clearly in like in the case of the local
highways panel the logical solution is
for the ealc
to appoint
a paris representative to serve on the
the jsc as they do for other
organizations that is
thank you councillor darum councillor
siegel you wanted to come back
uh yeah thank you chairman uh council
government there may spring point
however uh the council did oppose the
elc about continuing the process of
appointing
representatives from the paris and town
council and the elc were quite happy
for us to take over and the elc weren't
really that bothered about continuing
with that process
so
hence why we are now doing it directly
to all parish councils
right thank you very much so um
councillor chan are you going to clarify
your proposal
i think the appropriate place
that i could see
was to be actually probably
trying to get better um
under stage one i think where actually
uh para three referred to the leader of
the council will be notified and all
complaints against district councillors
and generally kept advised but also i
think their suitable wording could be
applied i'm sure mr quelch will
confidentially
um
of any complaint about the group
a group member
i mean as councillor john said you can
go into all the details i think
it would
be something
um that
it counts for civil highlighted and i
would
that's what i think that proposal should
who be up um i think the original
document that went to um
the jsc was saying that northern town
council and burnhamtown townsend should
be the ones appointing the parish rep
and again it was councillor that
actually felt that the opportunity
should be given to all parish councils
to nominate should they not then come
forward the backflip would be to go to
that so i think that again showed me
very great fairness and sensibilities
regarding the jsc committee and trying
to get the articles right and fair and
proper and i thank councillor for that
thank you i'm going to
ask mr quelch
where we can stand on this uh just at
the back there please
could you advise mr grouch well of
course uh chairman you can do all of
those things that members have mentioned
it's entirely up to members what they do
and obviously the
the uh proposal i meant amending
um that counselor chairman's before of
course that can happen and of course it
can go
in
three i was just a little little
uncertain
there seems to be to me a little
uncertainty me as m.o when i'm told well
not to give all the specific details i
don't quite know what that means
um
so do i would i therefore give details
of the complaint or would i just simply
say a complaint had been made without
giving any details at all i think there
needs to be some definition on that
yes can we just um
can we just clarify then counselor
channel if you could be clear about your
proposal please hang on a sec we'll just
wait for the michael mike thank you
well
chairman i think in the
in the first instance what the leader
gets i mean there's the way that you can
be told about the complaint without
listening sorry i can't quite hear you
cancer channel sorry i've got the mic
here chairman i think really in a
similar vein i'm sure the leader is
initially informed of a complaint
you'd be told what the complaint was but
you wouldn't necessarily have all the
detail within an email that may be all
the verbatim wording that may be applied
it could be just um you know a
disrespect shown to a counselor or
something i'm not advocating there needs
to be the continued going on advice
because i think that's covered up
covered on later in
the
document the article whether the group
member were a group leader be told but i
think that it's initially if a
complaint's in then the leader of any
group and i'm not just talking about
myself because uh councillor stan being
both the leader she's also the leader of
the independence and if you know we had
other groups come on board who knows in
the future so
what i'm saying is it could be just
highlighting what the complaint is but
not necessarily being given the text of
the email that might contain greater
detail and then i'm not saying that
necessarily um that group
uh leader has to be you know perhaps of
the same degree i'm sure mr crouch might
have with the leader of the council but
i think it is important and fair
and in the right way forward as
councilor siddall tried to put over very
well and he did in fact i just think
that is what should happen under nickel
3 and i think that's appropriate wording
can be applied chairman thank you all
right thank you before i come to
councillor thompson i would just like to
hear what um the leader has to say about
that sorry can we have the mic up here
maisie please
all right okay no let's say we are
that's fine good
side thank you
she's being
thank you i think a little bit of
background from mr quelch might help
here about the actual procedure
because at what stage does everybody get
involved because i'm i'm really i think
people's complaints and things should be
kept private there's a policy about it
and i'm a great believer that people's
independence and privacy should be kept
for as long as possible and there's also
the issues if somebody has a
problem with the actual leader of their
party i i i feel a little bit that it
needs to be heard a bit fuller and that
further and i'd like mr coach's advice
on that please what he feels
mr crouch
okay my advice uh chairman
at the jsc was exactly that which the
leader has mentioned that
the fewer people that know about it the
better because the process is
confidential
up until the point if there is a formal
investigation then normally the results
of the formal investigation will then
deal with in public in jfc that's the
norm
but up to that particular point
confidentiality is important in my view
particularly if you're going for an
informal resolution
or some other matter the less people
that know about that the more likely
there is to be some success in that
process
so
my advice to jsc was the fewer the
people the better
now whether you feel the fewer the
better should also include the group
leaders obviously a matter for members
but confidentiality is something that is
important and i think
i do understand now what council channel
is talking about
when i inform the leader of the council
i generally
um i generally
would send the complaint itself unless
it was so long
and complex that it needs summarizing so
i would do exactly the same to the the
group leader if that was included in the
procedure
all the evidence obviously i wouldn't
pass on but the actual text of the
complaint i would
that's how it stands at the moment with
the leader of the council
all right thank you um i'm going to have
mrs thompson first councillor thompson
first
then councillor siddal and then go back
to mrs stamp
council stamp so councillor thompson
excuse me thank you chairman um
yeah i i think it makes it only makes
sense to have whichever group leader if
we do this should have whatever the
information the leader of the council
gets uh otherwise the leader of the
council would be in the slightly silly
position of being told one thing in one
email and something a bit different in
another since she in this case is also
the leader of the group
and in regard to confidentiality i can't
help thinking that
puts members of the leaders group
whoever it is and whoever they are or
something of a disadvantage compared to
other members if they're if their leader
knows about complaints against them and
another group's leader
doesn't it it just seems slightly
batty to me and i
would certainly recommend that both
leaders get the same information at the
same time both the leader of the council
and the leader of the group if of course
it's not the same person
thank you councillor siddal at the
uh back you chairman yeah i i agree with
council thompson uh i also question the
modernity officers questioning the
morals of any group leader
um and the fact that they wouldn't keep
something confidential
group leaders are given confidential
information all the time
and they keep it confidential so
therefore i see no reason why any group
leader would not be informed about a
complaint and i think it is about being
fair and reasonable
okay thank you i'm going to go now to
councillor chana
and then i'm going to go for the vote
for a vote on this councillor probably
has said exactly what i was going to say
he we seem to be having telepathic wave
sports through a number of meetings
recently so i won't i won't uh label the
point
okay sorry finally the leader
and then i'm going to go for a vote on
the oh i see this i'm sorry i can't see
you mr crouch okay come to me
okay if you stay there maisie thank you
counselor stan thank you chairman um i i
don't think mr quelch was questioning
anybody's
morals or confidentiality in that nature
and i just wanted to put that on record
i don't believe um that is the issue
thank you
thank you mr crouch finally yeah that's
exactly what i was going to say i think
councillor has misread what i said i i
just said confidentiality was important
i wasn't in any way as the leader said
questioning the morality
of any group leader so um i'm sorry that
council siddha thought i was saying that
i most definitely for the record was not
saying
that right okay i think we'll uh we'll
go to the vote on this proposal then
[Music]
is that seconded
it's not seconded
all right this second is okay thank you
very much
councillor lagan
can we be clear councillor channel on
your proposal that the leader is to be
informed in the event of a complaint
your proposal is that the leader of the
group uh the leader of the council if
they're the same person uh would be
informed in the event of a complaint
under three i think i mentioned
paragliding i believe councillor
seconded it chairman and we're talking
about the text of the complaint is that
correct
yeah
it is right okay members i hope we are
clear on that uh we have had a request
for a recorded vote which
uh which has been seconded
uh so could i ask
tara please to call the role
i thank you members if you could
indicate thought against rob stone
please when i call your name starting
with councillor bassinger please
okay
thank you councilman
councillor bell
councillor voice
council mrs channel
councillor durham
councillor edwards
councillor heard
abstain
councillor hull
councillor keys or councillor lagan
councillor mays four councillor morley
councillor morris the whole procedure is
rubbish
thank you councillor none
councillor siddall
councillor stamp the yates
councillor stevens
councillor stilts
councillor swain
councillor mrs thompson
council miss white
chairman the results of that are sixteen
four five against and one abstention
thank you chairman that is carried then
in that case
any other business council of messenger
there isn't okay no other business thank
you very much
oh are you happy to agree the minutes
thank you members
uh we move on to agenda item eight which
is minutes of meetings of the council
uh and we move uh that the minutes of
the council i propose that we note these
on block do i have a seconder councillor
maize
can we agree by ascent members
thank you very much
agenda item nine question in accordance
with procedure rule 6 3 of which notice
has been given i have none
agenda item 10 statement of community
involvement these are found members on
pages 51-12
this is the adoption of the statement of
the community involvement and i'll hand
over to the leader council staff
thank you thank you chairman members and
the purpose of the report is the draft
statement of community involvement the
sci set out how the council will consult
with stakeholders in the community on
planning policy consultants
neighbourhood
consultation sorry neighbourhood plans
and planning applications the six-week
consultation has finished and the
responses received have informed
revisions to the draft sci and cancer is
now requested to adopt the sti at
appendix one
i hope everybody's ready there are a few
people who responded on a few parish
councils so the recommendation that i'm
going to put chairman if that's all
right with you that the council adopts
the 2021 statement of community
involvement appendix one do i have a
second
councillor maze thank you
councillor chana
i think the mike's behind you yeah thank
you
thank you chairman can i just say um
what an excellent report i thought that
was and the compilation of the
consultation responses in the very clear
manner
that the work was presented and i found
it very very refreshing and encouraging
to see that the parish council i mean
apart from essex county council and the
nhs i thought to have the parish
council's responses in the detail that
they were
and um to note that the officer who
assessed it all and gave very clear
reasons as to why some changes would be
made to the document to why some other
others weren't i think it was
encouraging to see the parish council's
views being reflected or
actually having an effect on that
document and i would like to thank the
officers for that but especially i would
like to highlight leonie alpin who i
think
i'm not singling out anyone but really
i'm aware leonie did the report and a
great look at the work and i thought the
way it was presented the clarity in
which the representations were put the
way that malden district council
comments were given in terms of the
response so it was clear and also where
the changes were or what changes would
be made and where to find them in the
document i would just like to say um
extend my thanks to leonie open i'm sure
probably all members likewise and i'm
sure those that are involved in the
consultation process and gave responses
um also will be grateful the way that
report has come forward and of course i
support the recommendation chairman
thank you
thank you very much council chan it's
always always good to have such positive
feedback thank you so members can we
agree this by ascent
you're abstaining okay thank you very
much
okay um
is there a record is there a seconder
for a recorded vote
no your abstention is recorded
agenda item 11 taxi and private hire
policy these are found on pages 121-188
i draw your attention to the
supplementary pack page three to ninety
six
uh leader
thank you chairman members officers
obviously we had an update a late
updated
report i hope some of you have managed
to read it if not all of you
i think the
items highlighted in yellow was the
editions that came on late
so the purpose of the report is to
introduce an overarching taxi and
private hire based policy based on
recommendations in the department of
transport
statutory guidance pulling together all
the council's policies conditions bylaws
and procedures into one document to
amend the existing council policy and
conditions to reflect the
recommendations made by the dft
and to outline the consultation process
with stakeholders including the taxi and
private hire trade to adopt the vehicle
inspection standards manual based on the
standards manual sorry members based on
the best practice guide produced by the
department of transport hackney carriage
and private hire inspection technical
officers group that was the new bits on
on their members so the recommendations
are
um that the draft overaction policy on
taxi and private hire be approved that
the amendments to the existing policy
and licensing conditions be approved
members
that the consultation process be
approved and that the vehicle inspection
standards manual be approved for
immediate use
i'd like to propose that chairman thank
you do i have a seconder
councillor maze thank you
members i'll open this debate to the
floor uh councillor
councillor edwards sorry
is there any more light here at all
thank you chairman
uh an observation really can i draw
members attention to page 183
appendix one or appendix f
183 is this in the supplementary pack
but no it won't be there next one or
appendix f there's two apparently yeah
sorry it's the first one yeah
item
five motors no longer exist
carry on item five yeah
quest motors no longer exist
that's correct no it doesn't it doesn't
exist no that's right thank you
okay that's noted any other any other
member wish to speak on this
in that case um
yes casa stephen sorry
it's very could we have a little bit
more light on in here dude
i'm trying to work on it okay thank you
councillor stevens
two questions um one is i noticed there
was nothing about covid in the taxi
or the private hire documents at all
which seems surprising at the moment
because it's
it's such a
close
you know you've got passenger and a taxi
driver sitting right next to each other
and i wondered if we should have
anything in there about that
um and the other is that it states in
there that the taxi must display a
notice saying if they don't take various
forms of payment but there's nothing
about cash
and i think we've moved on now haven't
we people are not using cash
cash has become more of the exception
and i think that should be in there
thank you
okay any other members wish to speak on
this
in that case um
mr holmes did you want to come back on
that
we'll just wait for the microphone sorry
it won't be a second
thank you i'm happy to put those uh i
think well our minor changes to the team
that's put this guidance together and
remembers permission if that is
acceptable we can insert that if it's if
there's any particular reason why i
couldn't go in i can i can notify all
members
thank you for that to council saves our
members happy with those amendments
okay uh can we can we agree this all by
ascent then
your abstention is noted thank you
okay that's under rule 13 4 thank you
we move on then to agenda item 12 future
committee meeting arrangements this is
found on pages 189-194
this is to consider the ongoing
arrangements for committee meetings in
light of the changes in government
restrictions
leader
thank you chairman thank you members and
obviously you've just said it's to
consider the arrangements of committee
meetings united for changes to the
government restrictions um the
recommendations are members would you
like um mr dobson to take you through
the document before i put the
recommendations
or shall i just put the recommendations
i'm quite happy i'm going to put the
recommendations more than hopefully
the recommendations are that the council
reviews the options on appendix a and
agrees an approach noting potential
risks and additional resource
requirements little two that the council
reviews those litigations let out an
appendix a and confirm if any additional
measures are required members and little
three oh thank you very much great you
can see you can see the words now on the
page
that should be the government that the
government should
that should the government revise
legislation to
again allow for remote meetings the
corporate governance working group bring
a further report back
and now i'll hand over to mr dodson and
he can take us through the report i'm
sure members have mr dobson
good evening members
um further into the national relaxation
of covet rules
uh
changing down to guidance on the 19th of
july this paper's intended as a review
of our committee arrangements and the
mitigations we currently have in place
although the legislation has been
relaxed covert cases continue to
circulate and risks to staff and members
have been considered in the detail in
appendix a
many organizations have kept mitigations
in place that they had before the 19th
of july
with these um issues in mind and
obviously at present the the council
continues to operate to those
arrangements that were agreed by council
back in april um subject to any changes
following this report
the first table in appendix a
lists all of the current mitigations
that we have in place and the rationale
behind them and any current issues
the second table within appendix a
presents four options going forward as
well as a as potential issues and
benefits of each of them
the current arrangements are adding an
additional 0.5 fte additional resource
pressure
and obviously the cost of hall hire the
district planning and full council
meetings
members are asked to review the options
presented
in the detail in appendix a and degree
an option for future meeting
arrangements noting the potential risks
and costs highlighted
thank you chairman
thank you mr dodson uh i see a couple of
hands uh i think uh
councillors white was uh first
yes
i'd just like to put forward an argument
for option three um i mean i've been
very unwell i'm still undergoing
operations and i think for me this is
the most sensible option we do need to
get back in the chamber i i don't think
the sneeze screens do that much i'm
quite happy retaining a mask
all the way through
and i've had the residents in my ward um
thank me for the live streaming because
they're delighted to have to watch some
of them don't want to drive they don't
want to come out even pre-covered so i'd
like to propose that we accept option
three
um if that's not um agreed by the
members then possibly option four but
retaining the um
the live streaming and but i'll say i i
really like the idea of option three and
possibly we could put it forward to
review it at christmas time to see how
the covid cases are going i think we
need to be sensible but be mindful that
we could go into a really bad winter
again if we need to go back to remote
meetings we can thank you
just uh just to remind you um councillor
white that option four is no live
streaming
yeah yeah
so if you might come back i said you
know if everybody wants option four
which i hope they don't could we add the
live streaming as an option but
certainly i'd like to stay with option
three thank you okay thank you
councillor siddal next
uh thank you chairman uh i think we need
to go for a slightly more flexible
approach in terms of this there are
members
and also officers who are concerned
about kavid so i can understand the need
for us to move back to the chamber
however because the chamber is so small
it really does put us in very close
proximity
to other members and other officers
so my proposal would be that we
keep the full council and district
council meetings here at the stadium
all other council meetings return to the
chamber
and remove the screens
and if
individuals want to wear mass they can
do so but that then gives us more
flexibility provides greater protection
for members
uh ensuring that we can create two meets
keep two metres apart
and we continue with the live streaming
thank you
thank you is that is that seconded by
anybody
cancer channel okay thank you
that said stamp sorry yeah okay
right
council and none next please
just at the end thank you
thank you very much
you've only got to look at the news
to realise that this awful pandemic has
not gone away yet some of us indeed have
been
touched by it personally with our
families
and you know i'm disappointed that what
hasn't been said so far
is something about what the officers
have been doing to help us
i'd like to commend the hard work of the
officers
and what they've done to mitigate things
for us
to make us as safe as we possibly can be
and also them of course
yes there's been a cost to the
organization but that cost helps ensure
democracy and representation uh and
continuity and i think whatever we
decide tonight we need to continue to
mitigate the risk
thank you very much councillor morris
thank you mr chairman i'd just like to
point out to the character this chamber
that
coveted
by
mortality and transmission
is comparable with the flu
i'm sure our emergency services and
essential workers will be absolutely
rolling about on the floor laughing at
us
for me taking mitigating circumstances
when they've
come into contact with this virus
all the way through and we are talking
about silly screens and paper masks that
won't do a thing we're also talking
about tests that are inaccurate even the
bloke that made them have said that and
i i just uh whilst we need to protect
our vulnerable
we also need to get back to uh normal as
normal as we can get thank you
thank you councillor chana
okay i'll take councillor thompson
thank you chairman um
yeah i i very strongly support
councillor white i think option three we
should do option three at least uh
because it certainly doesn't prevent any
members of staff or any members for that
matter i mean i don't see why they
couldn't be accommodated by requests
with screens if they want them if people
feel they're particularly vulnerable or
particularly worried about it
but i think we should move back to the
chamber and i do thank the staff for all
the work they've done certainly echo
council and none in that but it is an
awful lot of work for them to schlep
everything down here for every meeting
that we hold down here um and that that
can't be
that can't be a small thing
and i think we can maintain a suitable
distance in the chamber and i don't see
a great advantage in being here if we
haven't got the screens but
i would certainly second option three um
and hopefully with a review to you know
at christmas to see what else we could
do but again like councillor white i
think if we do go for option four it
should be with the screening because
there are very few good the streaming
because there are very few good things
to come out of the pandemic but like her
residents mine have said how much they
like the live streaming and i think you
should stick with that as far as i'm
concerned on a permanent basis thank you
chen thank you very much and next door
councillor durham other side maisie
thank you
thank you thank you very much chairman
chairman i think i think it's fair to
say that towards the first quarter of
last year when the pandemic uh started
and was declared nobody was really
certain um about the transmissibility or
indeed uh the the um how dangerous this
virus was
we've learned such a lot in the
intervening time
it was initially regarded as being
similar to the flu we now know much more
as does every single country across the
globe this is not just a uk thing
we now know that long covid is a really
serious condition i know two people now
suffering from long covered i'm afraid
it's one of those things that can't be
denied
however
we now are
in a situation where the majority of
people
nearly 80 percent of adults in this
country have now been double vaccinated
the question whether we have boosters or
something for government
i think the other thing we need to take
account of is
these screens
are actually useless
they actually hinder the business of the
council because we can't see or hear
each other properly it's even worse in
the chamber and i think it's also been
proved with the benefit of hindsight in
fairness and medical research that the
perspex visors have very little impact
the only thing that prevents aerosol
transmission
completely or largely as an fp3 class of
face mask the normal face masks these
fp2 masks
do very little unless they're absolutely
brand new
but that being said if we don't choose
to move back to the chamber into some
form of normality now when are we going
to
we are acutely aware that there will be
another spike in infections when the
schools go back and as winter approaches
but we have to make the move at some
time
now i'm more than happy to move back
into the chamber as it is
if people want to wear a mask and that
is the situation at essex county council
where our next full council meeting is
moving back to the chamber which is
people are in equally close proximity as
they are in our chamber
and we are only required to wear masks
when standing and moving around the
building they are removed during the
during the debate so chairman
i honestly think that now is the time to
take this action
to start to get back to normal
people now have to take their own
measures and what they feel comfortable
with and protect themselves this is all
about protecting ourselves and making
our own decisions and if you want to
wear a mask then wear a mask and i will
choose to
when i don't feel comfortable and at the
moment i'm fairly comfortable without
wearing a mask
and the other point of course the live
streaming is absolutely essential and if
one good thing has come out of the covid
it has been the live streaming so that
the residents of this district can see
the council at work because it simply
isn't practical for them to come into
the um into the chamber and into the
council offices all right thank you
thank you councillor i'm going to move
to councillor now
um
i've enjoyed the debate and i'm pleased
that the members are feeling that the
time is right to go back into the
chamber there's a couple of things i
want to say first of all i want to echo
councillor none
as comments
and that of other members for the
officers because the due diligence that
was put in in a very worrying time
and the measures that were put in um
were right and proper
i'm sorry castlelane could you just
speak up a wee bit please thank you
sorry um yeah the uh the measures that
the officers put in at the time were
right and proper um so i just want to
record my thanks for that
there's been a lot there's a lot of
guidance that's gone out there um kobe
being a real issue in in a global
pandemic causing uh untold deaths and an
awful lot of issues
um but the guidance of the government
have put out we've got to remember that
as a as a council we're covered by laws
and we have to have a safe place of work
and the chamber is a safe place of work
so in the guidance that's out there
we can work safely by sitting side by
side it's something that they've had in
there from basically from day.
and i think it would be very important
to allow members to take personal
responsibility but also with a slightly
different take on councillor durham to
also have respect for other people
in the respect of trying to do their
best to keep those individuals as safe
as possible because we do have people
with with health conditions that we
should consider so i'm prepared to
support number three but i think we
should really look at making sure that
we have you know
natural flow tests
you know as an optional thing for people
mask sanitizers and all of those good
things
and wear masks if people want to
and look look and be respectful within
the chamber don't sit in the seats where
we used to sit if somebody feels
vulnerable put them at the end of the
horseshoes where they're further away
from other people than before so i'm
very keen to get back into the chamber
and would support option three thank you
thank you council
i'll move now to councillor chana and
then councillor slain
council turned it down the old maze has
got that well done
some of the things i was going to say
have been covered by councillors
thompson durham and lagan what i would
say is i think i heard quite clearly
what council of white was saying go with
uh option three it will remove the whole
higher costs uh stadium availability
officers the resource there requiring
the pa system and everything so there's
savings for the taxpayer but equally she
did make it clear i think about um
looking at a review to see what the
landscape was like i think she suggested
uh sort of christmas time or after a few
months and by that time the schools will
have been back and we're moving into a
sort of winter period so i i think that
was where councillor white was very very
um sensible to actually apply that
review which she indicated in her
proposal thank you chairman
thank you councillor swain
yes thank you uh chairman
um
referring to a previous comment i think
we have to um
recognize it in it
to a certain extent we are all
vulnerable with this
virus
and that is not like flu
particularly with the long-term
conditions that can develop um when it
comes to the idea of moving back into
the chamber um it's all very well
sitting side by side but
um
which would be okay with me on the outer
ring but the
people in the lower um well would have
people directly talking
down on behind them
um i would say i would suggest it's a
bit too soon to
change from the current arrangements
and in any case however we vote on this
chairman i think we should vote on the
option one
initially if only to discount it
thank you very much and councillor
stephens at the back
thank you chairman sorry i've just
managed masks yes i know i'm free to
wear a mask i'm free to wear kind of
whatever i like so people who are saying
to me oh emme you can wear a mask but
the mask is about me protecting you
from any disease i might have not the
other way around so it doesn't work to
just say well if you're feeling
vulnerable wear a mask
um
this is normal for me as a new new
counsellor having some meetings in here
it's just about level of risk we're
never going to say oh well let's come to
here instead and we get rid of all risks
obviously that's not the case but if we
go to the chamber for big meetings where
there are many of us and sit closer
together we're increasing the risk and i
don't see a queue of taxpayers saying
that we should do that
yes it's going to cost money to continue
doing this and if there are if there's
scientific evidence that says we don't
need these screens then yeah i'd be
happy with them going
but i don't want to increase my risk so
i want to stay here when there are large
highly populated meetings thank you
thank you very much
right members i think everybody's had an
opportunity who wishes to speak
um we have had a proposal which was by
councillor siddal uh to keep uh the uh
councillor white what was your proposal
quarterly review or a two monthly review
and depending on
covered
infection rates um changing
so i'd like it to be although it's
option three to be fluid and if there's
a spike in cases then we can revert we
can review and potentially revert back
to here
thank you
leader wishes to speak
thank you chairman i've taken on board
what everybody said but has not one of
you has mentioned the risks to the
officers and the staff
oh sorry i do apologize if you did i i
obviously missed it um i i have grave
concerns it was just we have discussed
this um
where i would sit at the top is quite
close
and i actually agree with cancer stevens
and cancer siddharth and councillor none
i partially agree with some of what the
other members have said but i for one
yeah i've i've been double jabbed but if
you actually look at the statistics at
the moment the people who are being
admitted straight back into hospital
again are people of my age um which i
know i only look 30 but believe me i'm
not twice that age
and and i i do think we have to be
really careful and for the sake of
postponing it until after the
period where we all believe and you've
said it tonight we're going to have a
spike
why can't we just keep it here until
most probably december just to make sure
what is the rush in going back i
understand there's a financial
implication i'm well aware of that
um but i i do not feel comfortable uh
myself so i will not be supporting
councillor white's motion thank you
thank you so just to clarify councillor
white you're you're advocating option
three is that correct
with a two to three month review right
okay
and that has been seconded
seconded by councillor boyce thank you
very much
right
members could ask you to
vote please
is that seconded
councillor lagan seconds that will have
a recorded vote on this
so members this is for option
three
to move all the meetings back to the
chamber remove social distancing but
with other current mitigations and
protocols in place
with live streaming and a review after
three months
okay tara if you could call the role
please thank you members if you could
indicate four against or abstain when i
call your name please starting me
counselor passenger
thank you councillor miss beale
councillor bell
councillor boyce
council mrs channel
councillor durham
councillor edwards councillor heard
against
councillor harlan
councillor keys oh councillor lagan
councillor mays
against councillor morley
councillor morris
councillor nunn
councillor
councillor stamp
councillor stevens
councillor stilts
councillor swain
councillor mrs thompson
councillor miss white
chairman the results of that are 13 4 8
against one abstention thank you
chairman
in that case that is carried
option
three it will be
yes mr council mr tom mr thompson
thank you chairman for letting me speak
on this um this is out of order and i
apologize um but could we look at
providing the
highest standard of mask to either staff
who would like to wear one or
members indeed who would like to wear
one given that you know this has not
been exactly unanimous that we go back
to the chamber with option three i'm
very glad that we are but if anyone is
nervous could about you know the
situation could we look at them being
provided with that level of mask
because we saved the money by not being
here as councilman durham has just
pointed out i mean it might not even
need a resolution i i've no idea perhaps
management could look at that but i'd
like to suggest it
right okay um well i understand that uh
but we we voted for it um as such i i i
genuinely do feel for
for those members
those officers
who have not had a say in this
i'll i'll actually go to perhaps mr
holmes if you'd like to make a comment
about these
additional masks
i'm sorry to put you on the spot mr
holmes but
well obviously we'll look at uh
protection for staff we have a duty of
care and responsibility for our staff so
it is so appropriate that that is
suitable we will do that and obviously
we can make that available for members
as well
yeah okay
right there's there are a number of
questions we we have we have voted on
this but i will i'll just take these
comments very briefly for those who
haven't spoken before and i'll start
with the council of voice i'm sorry i
know he's the furthest away
hang on a sec bob okay gentlemen all i
was going to point out is the uh
additional uh mitigation uh measures
could be covered in recommendation too
we have agreed recommendation one but we
have not got to two or three yet
um
yeah we've agreed those options no
chairman
there's a recommendation there's three
recommendations
on on the first page of the report
under the purpose of the report and the
second recommendation is that the
council reviews the mitigation set out
in appendix a and confirm if any
additional measures are required right
that covers mrs thompson's concerns
it does indeed that can cover mrs
thompson's concerns
yes councillor councillor mays
yeah thank you mr chairman i'd like to
come back to what councillor um stephen
said earlier
the purpose of a mask is only going to
be any good if we all wear them to
protect one another me wearing a mask
does not protect me
it protects you
and whilst i'm happy to wear a mask
others may not be and therefore they're
not protecting me
just a comment thank you
right okay uh leader
and while we're looking at the
mitigation what what concerns me is that
we already had mitigation in place like
the lateral flow tests
and and i feel strongly that councillors
who who didn't submit their requests or
didn't take them
should be made to do that now because we
are going to be closer together i think
more mitigation needs to be put in
what is your point of order
please
what is it you'd like what is your point
of order point of order i'm making is
the leader has just stated that people
should be forced to do medical
procedures that cannot be nuremberg code
i suggest you read it
all right mitigation thank you
um
no i don't think the leader said forced
either though right okay um
so have we got uh have we got uh the
recommendation please be quiet
councillor morris
can we have uh a
the recommendations can we agree the
recommendations members
that is noted
we move on
then to agenda item 12.
what additional
mitigation measures
under recommendation 2 the council is
recommending well i think they're set
out in appendix a are we actually
recommending that these extra special
masks be made available to uh members of
staff
and
members if they so wish
i think mr holmes has already answered
that question i think you'll be looking
into that
very well let me let me hear what
councillor bell has to say first
thank you mr chairman it's just a point
of information that the ffp-3s do
protect the wearer
i'm sorry
the ffp3 masters do protect the wearer
as well as others
all right that's that's uh so we have a
proposal uh
for this uh extra
protection
that's been seconded could i have a show
of hands please on that
those against
that is carried then thank you
any abstentions
one thank you
two that's noted
um
right are we all done with the
recommendations
can we agree those recommendations
sorry memphis i was just asking for
clarification in respect of
recommendation 2 which asks the council
review the mitigation set out in
appendix a and confirms if any
additional measures are required
um obviously we just agreed that those
additional ones i'm just trying to see
clarity i'll be saying that the existing
ones are still staying in place
i think if we if we move the meetings
back to the chamber we have to remove
the two meter social distancing
and the screens i think yes
right and in fact it goes back to normal
well look we've already taken a vote on
this is it
i'm not quite sure what members want to
do because we've already voted on this
uh i'll take councillor lagan first
right can i go to mr dodson first then
sorry i'm not i'm not sure what what you
what you'd come to me
oh sorry i thought you wanted to speak
okay counselor counselor lagan just uh
at the back there thank you
yeah thank you chair i'll be quite quick
um
because in the report there doesn't seem
to be a list of mitigations that we can
select from
so respectfully i would i would suggest
that we we
say our mitigations are side by side
working where possible provision of
masks ffp3 masks for members members to
undertake a lateral flow test if they
feel comfortable by doing so hand
sanitizer on each individual workstation
and i think that that would probably be
in line with what the government
guidelines stipulate and will be very
fair and equal to everybody
and very clear and succinct
okay can i just confirm turret were you
able to get that
you were great okay are members happy
with those mitigations in place
your extension is noted
right okay so we are also
the third one yeah third recommendation
that they should
okay
thank you very much
thank you members good right uh so we'll
move on then to agenda item 13.
uh planning advisory service review of
recommendations pages 195
to 210
and uh this is the report uh which will
be uh i'll hand over to leader
thank you chairman members the purpose
of this report is to provide considerate
feedback from the corporate governance
working group further to the
recommendations made in the report of
the past planning advisory service has a
local government association group that
are an authority voice in planning
policy providing consultancy peer
support and resource to help local
authorities respond to planning reform
and embed best practice
um i'm not going to present the report
it was agreed that council siddal will
as the chairman of the corporate
governance working group and cancer
siddle are you okay to do the
recommendations
okay we're just taking the mic over now
to councillor
uh thank you chairman in 2020 the lga
and within that the paz
were asked to review our planning
committees
the paz uh are an lga group that's an
authoritative voice in planning policy
and resources
to help
planning authorities to reform and embed
best practice
has produced a report with a series of
recommendations
these went through thoughtful
consideration at the corporate working
governance group
the corporate working and governance
group upon reviewing the report is a
presenting to the council
our recommendations for adoption that
are detailed at appendix a
the majority of these are procedural
matters however recommendation 11 to
move away from individual area planning
committees requires a constitutional
change and approval of appendix b to the
report if agreed by members
the working group went through a great
deal of discussion and the rationale for
the change is that it will ensure good
practice and ensuring consistency when
making planning decisions
it will prevent issues that have
occurred the members over the past year
or so
it will ensure that members can be more
objective in their decision making and
at the same time will still be
democratically involved as they will be
able to make representation
at the planning committee for
applications in the ward
with one planning committee it will
enable legal legal representation at
every meeting
improving the legal basis of decisions
uh the detail in the report is obviously
given and it will benefit the council in
terms of staffing and resources as well
at this stage i am not going to move the
recommendations because i would like
because this is such an important issue
for the council i would like that the
debate occurs first
thank you very much uh councillor durham
then lagan and then none
white thank you
thank you thank you chairman we find
ourselves back in a similar position to
where we've been
in the past
more than more than once
and on every occasion members expressed
concern that a single planning committee
would diminish their ability to give
local input
for a particular planning application
but this simply is not the case
as members we're often asked to support
our residents wishes and those of parish
councils
often in pretty strong terms i certainly
have
when we get to planning committees we
are obliged as we've all been trained to
follow the ldp
and
extent planning policies which could
well be contrary to the local wishes in
order to comply with our legal legal
obligations when determining those
applications
to follow policy we may have to vote
against the local views
which can be damaging to our position as
ward members a single planning committee
should allow ward members freedom to
speak
and if even to grandstand for the
benefit of local opinion
but if not a member of the committee we
wouldn't have the honoris job to vote in
short we would have the best of both
worlds this means that we could support
the local views
and uphold the master ward member
avoiding potential conflict with our
parish councils and our residents
we must start to get consistent
decisions one of the benefits as we've
already discussed this evening has been
the the live streaming uh and when
there's not been much on tv i've been
watching both central and southeast
committees as well as obviously
attending north west
members it is absolutely staggering how
different
area committees operate and the
attitudes of members
towards the application of planning
is is really quite marked
if this continues we are certain to face
challenge ins
at some point in the future and whether
we like it or not there is a real risk
that our ability to to determine our own
applications in the future may be
removed from us this is not a thinly
veiled threat it has happened mhclg
have gone in to authorities and removed
their right when they have not been
determining applications properly
chairman a single planning committee is
really the only way and the single
planning committee comprised of
committed and well-trained members
at their own wish and and chairman over
the last few years when i have met other
members many many other members from our
authorities
they are astounded we still have area
committees and when they say you know
are you on the planning committee and i
explain how we go they go good gracious
the last committee i want to be on is
planning because it puts you in an
invidious situation with your residents
for the reasons i've just expressed so
it certainly does not diminish our right
as members to
represent the views of our constituents
in fact it enhances them thank you
thank you councillor durham councillor
lagan next
just behind you thank you uh thank you
chair um i i have a complete different
polls apart opinion from councillor
durham um although i respect some of his
his views that he's put in there i think
that those of us that that stood well
all of us that stood for election the
planning was probably one of the biggest
issues that were on it the development
perceived over development concreting
over the district
it was something that people feel very
passionate about and representation
via election
into individual committees
for me is absolutely critical to
represent the residents views
i think when you you have a closed group
and you can say 13 people i think i read
politically balanced well i thought
planning wasn't politically balanced or
politically motivated
i think individual opinions and options
of people who are close on the ground
to determine small medium and large
applications is absolutely critical
that's why the people put us there i
don't think that we should be uh be
fearful of making decisions that groups
will come and take us or take our
decision-making processes away i'm
uncomfortable extremely with this
proposal
the cost that's that's levied in the
report
i think there's about 65 000 residents
in the malden district well that's 88
pence per person
to have representation if we stick as we
are i i enjoy the challenges of planning
it's the most frustrating thing i find
it in council
but i feel as an elected representative
of the people to be able to go and make
those representations to learn to
develop to stand up for things that
sometimes you have to stand up for
and and vote in a way that the law
allows
is the just and right thing to do so i
can't support this without further
information on how many determinations
have been undertaken by
officers that have been to appeal how
many by members because then we can test
our own abilities whether that that part
of the the equation falls into it so i'm
sorry i i can't support this and and i
feel we will be letting the the members
of the public down and whether it's mrs
smith who has a small application in or
a large application that needs
determining i think it should be the
members on each of the area committees
and the full council for large
applications thank you
thank you very much councillor lagan um
council nun you didn't did you
okay thank you very much uh councillor
white at the at the back there please
maisie thank you
yeah okay um thank you mr chairman for
letting me speak i mean i just wanted to
add some more on from what council
lagoon said um in my email inbox i get
95 percent of the emails are for
planning
fewer for bins and the odd ones are for
highways which we pass on to assets
county council looks at nothing to do
with malden
now this main committee that's been
proposed is only going to have 16
members so what that means is when you
get something in your award it might be
that you are not on that committee so
you can't you can you can talk about it
but no more than any member of the
public can you've got no say on what
happens and when we talk about
consistency we recently had a barn in
pearly and the committee approved it i
think it was pretty much unanimous and
the officers went away they didn't issue
a decision notice because of an appeal
in althorn
and so it came back to northwest and we
approved it again actually i couldn't
vote the second time because i arrived
late um i was holding traffic
um but it's this we know and what the
argument was all about sustainability we
knew that application in pearly was
sustainable i raised in the meeting that
all the appeals in pearly have been lost
because they've all been considered to
be sustainable they've all been allowed
whereas all thorn they had all they've
all been dismissed and we know this
because we are in our areas and we know
our areas and the as say the only thing
that anybody's interested in well
primarily for me is planning that's what
i was elected for sometimes it's really
uncomfortable but i've always done what
i think is best every single time
sometimes i regret what i've done
sometimes i sit back and think yep that
was right but i've always done what i
believe
to be is the right decision
and following from council lag and said
it works out the saving is only hundred
pounds a meeting when i canvassed my
residence they said eleven hundred
pounds that's cheap because we get
ordinary people like you
and the officers recently they've lost
appeals with plant pack for a fence
well
i didn't you know for me that wouldn't
have been a problem so it's not just us
that gets it wrong it's everybody gets
it wrong and as for legal representation
just give us an email and we can read
that before the meeting and take it into
account we don't need to have a legal
officer on hand for small applications
extensions or garages or single houses
that are inconsequential so i'd like to
put a motion forward that we do not
accept this option and that we do
keep remain keeping the um
three main planning committees because i
feel that we must keep our democracy
it's vitally important as members that
we keep our democracy and we keep our
decision making thank you
thank you very much that's that's noted
i would like a little bit more debate on
that first councillor chana is next i
think just down at the back maisie
so i'm happy councillor thompson's
coming
first and i'll listen to further debate
councillor thompson
thank you chairman um
i just want to say i mean
yes we want to represent our residents
of course we do but i think there's a
tendency to lose sight of the fact that
planning is not a democratic process
it involves planning law
you know we cannot do what we think is
right for our local residents we must do
what is right for the district as a
whole as set out in our policies
specifically in our local development
plan
and in fact councillor jarvis he's not
here but he won't mind me saying because
it's a matter of public record that he
has actually suggested that board
members should not be allowed to vote on
applications in their ward you know
there are other points of view and i
believe
i i agree with councillor durham that it
is very easy
to um to get sucked in really it's a
feeling that you need to support your
residents because you want to
but
in fact when it comes to it you cannot
make that you cannot
make a lawful decision that supports
what they want and it's a very difficult
position to be in
and yes i i applaud councillor white for
being prepared to
be in that position as i am myself
but we have to follow the local plan
that's how it is this is not a
democratic process i only wish it were
thank you
thank you um councillor that was that
your turn was it
i said i'd wait to listen to the debate
what i would say is i i did say i can i
can hear points from all members across
the floor the varying views germany in
fact i was one of those that most
certainly in the past when we looked i
think in this advocated remaining with
the three area committees however i can
see merits in many of the paz
recommendations and certainly about
legal representation i differ slightly
from council writing that i do think we
can't necessarily rely on mr lee
and the planning offices initially
sometimes provide the level of the legal
advice we might require and certainly
i'm aware of a committee recently an
aero planning committee where i think
some legal advice or from advice would
have assisted in the in the position of
committee found itself and i won't
highlight what it was but it was an
interesting one to watch what i would
also say is chairman regarding
councillor lagan
i know in the past when we did have what
i would call the white coats in at one
time i did defending get a load of
information regarding actually
comparative mem member and officers
because there is quite a significant um
delegated at the moment i know we're not
as high as other authorities and i've
been watching the appeal um outcomes and
in fact some of the officer
recommendations of refusal obviously
were carried through um under delegated
and they've been overturned by the
planning inspectorate so there might be
further information however i do think
we do have to look at the district as a
whole and i know some people might not
think that forty or thousand as a
savings a lot but in the climate climate
we're in um there are financial
considerations but as well as of course
representing the views of our residents
and regarding the local plan what i
would say yes
you could you determine planning
applications
in compliance with the ldp unless there
are other material planning
considerations that consider that you
may be able to consider otherwise
otherwise with all due respect we
wouldn't necessarily need and i will say
there's planning officers and even
ourselves we could just have a computer
where we pump it all through so i think
there's a number of competing arguments
here chairman and i'm interested to hear
what other members have to say as well
before i um come down on the way forward
regarding my hand which way it goes
thank you
thank you councillor china councillor
stevens is next and then i'll go to
councillor swain
over to the left
and then council location council swain
the councillor
council stephen's first and then
councillor swain
thank you chair um yes a couple of my
points have been made so i'll leave
those um but i would certainly like to
see more data um i'd want to understand
why we're getting excessive call-ins is
that because members are actually being
advised to call things in when maybe
it's not necessary
um yeah i'd want
excuse me i'd want to see more data
around that um
it says in the report that there's an
opportunity and i mean councillor durham
just painted a lovely picture of not
having the responsibility to be on a
planning committee but being able to you
know rock up and say your piece which
sounds great and i actually make it
makes me wonder well how would we find
people who would be willing to be
on the planning committee
and if they were is that going to
warp the
amount of hours that people have to
spend on council business and can we do
that mid-year when people are already
committed to well to the other
committees if we were to do it perhaps
it should start in may not at this time
of year thank you thank you very much
and councillor swain and then it will be
councillor keys at the end here amazing
um yes uh thank you chairman um i think
the arguments for the single um
committee are pretty flimsy
and particularly compared with the
arguments in favor of the the status quo
the
legal presence i i can hardly see when
that is really relevant but because it
the issues are usually planning issues
and we look to the
offices for guidance on that
and as for consistency i mean
what look may look like a similar
situation in one area may have different
circumstances elsewhere so it's it's not
so cut and dried
the other problem with a single
committee is
that
people who are
not
familiar with an area are like likely to
be
more indifferent
and to simply follow the um
planning office's guidance i don't think
that would be the same
level of involvement
as far as
this question of
representing your local interests
um
i don't see that as an issue really um
i'm on a district and on town council
and i can
which we say contribute
at town council but i like the other um
members in the similar position make the
disclaimer that i might take a different
view at district level and there's very
good reason for that because when it
comes to the area committee you have so
much more information
um and guidance to uh come to a full
decision instead of a rather
off-the-cuff one
and i i don't have any problem with that
um
the other problems with this single
committee is um that it would have to be
politically balanced and the whole point
if it
of such a committee would be it should
be geographically balanced rather than
political but that isn't something that
we could avoid
um
so i i
on this question of consistency again
um
the
um we there's two one or two things we
could do to improve the situation and i
think what we must try and make the
situation the current system work better
um i think uh the question of call-ins
um is a partly a failure of
communication and because
parish representatives or parish
committees
perhaps don't trust what the officers
may do on an application so they call it
in
um just to be sure that the thing is
properly discussed
and on the question of
experience
um
if you had a single committee you would
tend to have people who concentrated on
planning and others would perhaps
take less interest in what is a very
important function i think everybody
every member
can and should be
what you say up to scratch on how to
deal with a planning application in
front of them and to realize that they
have to build a case before their
position
based on
policies in the in the ldp which
we all ought to be familiar with
and on an understanding of material
considerations
and if we bear those in mind um uh any
member can make a valid contribution and
not be open to um
criticism
thank you okay thank you very much
indeed um councillor keys is next behind
you maisie
and then it'll be councillor boyce at
the back
a lot of what i was going to say has
been said but i absolutely thrive at
northwest planning i really look forward
to it and i've been commended tonight on
some of the
comments i said on the training that we
had tuesday night was it which i thought
was great now i was voted
to represent my ward and 90 percent of
my emails are about planning
so i will call them in and yes i do
struggle sometimes to find policies to
call them in but i normally get there in
the end and
i know i don't look it but i'm 49 in
november and i'm fortunate to know live
where i was born so i know a lot of the
area in great tottenham and the
surrounding areas so as mr i can't think
of the council's name
individual every application is judged
on the merits in front of you whether
it's not in the envelope outside the
village boundaries we all judge on what
we can do i'm not a trained officer and
yes i do have
some disagreements with mr lee over
there but i hope he doesn't take
hambridge of it so yes if there is one
planning committee i'll be more than
happy to sit on it and i'd also like to
be the chairman so i've got no problems
in sitting on any planning committee
thank you
thank you very much um
councillor boyce and then it'll be
councillor edwards so right near where
you are amazing just just wait there for
a second that's fine thanks
thank you chairman um local government
only exists by the will of parliament
so
if parliament says
we don't like what you're doing they
stop us doing it
i
i've always consistently when the
opportunity arose has voted for one
planning committee
however
i'm now starting to think that
what is the purpose of being an elected
member
we are constantly told
that
we
can't
do this and we can't do that
we can only do
what the local government act says we
can do
anything else
is ultraviolets
when i first became a councillor
members
allocated council houses to the people
that they knew
in their
area they knew that needed
the council house
that
facility was taken away from us
we were told that
it was the housing need
from somebody from timbuktu
um i know shall i say from um
the midlands or the north of england
outside of our district
so again i say what is the use of being
an elected
member
we mustn't
um i i was told just recently that this
paz people who is some sort of quango of
government i assume
has said we can't now
debate motions
on the table
you've you've got to let
all the questions and answers be
uh answered before
you can have a motion
to approve or
not
an application
that is without our constitution our
constitution says you can't debate
anything unless it's in the form of
emotion
so chairman i have changed my view
and i think
that
to
try and stick up for our local democracy
that we need to keep the three planning
uh committees thank you okay i'm
grateful for that thank you uh it'll uh
if you could just wait there we'll do
cancel the whole but councillor edwards
was next i think
just at the front maisie thanks
thank you
i was not what i was thinking has been
said
one of the issues i think is consistency
which i think council swain has already
touched upon
um between the three area committees it
would be interesting interesting to see
an investigation between the
results of all the three committees as
to
the number of appeals the number of
uh
decisions made to see if they are
similar or not i think an investigation
this could should be
delayed until an investigation is
actually made
but i do agree with uh
some of the other uh comments regarding
local knowledge that's important
so it is a bit of
there's a bit of an advantage on both
sides
is the way best to put it thank you all
right thank you very much i'm going to
go now to councillor hull and then i'll
go back to councillor seattle at the
back maisie thank you
what do you want to say something all
right okay hang on a second
thank you captain hole first
i'd like to say um
i think it's quite a privilege being on
the committee to the council the um bill
captain committee um and there's been so
much to learn and i'd like to thank the
officers for putting their time in to be
teaching us all they are teaching us and
i think only having 13 people to make
the decisions especially when it's our
local people
our local areas we do need um
as bob said and the local is better um
and
i would go i would
like to keep it as it is
okay thank you
um leader
thank you
thank you chairman um i actually
disagree slightly um with voting on the
motion tonight i i actually think that
what councillor edwards has said
um i did mention about having the data
for we used to get
data for southeast planning northwest et
cetera central to say how many appeals
had been lost the officer's
recommendations what members had
lost and i think sometimes we need more
information i think cancer stevens
mentioned some information as well and i
would like to do a i know i'm going to
wait for cancer siddle to do a counter
proposal
um thank you councillor siddel but i i
think um it would be better if we got
more information and also looked at the
whole of the planning system because i
think we need to address the calling as
well so why don't we come back with a
package that is in its entirety rather
than just vote on tonight but that's my
view thank you i'm going to go to cancer
signature
thank you leader councillor
thank you chairman and thank you leader
uh so having listened to the debate and
and it is something that is it's a very
cultural change in terms of the council
in terms of this movement and and there
are a lot of members who have discomfort
with this particular proposal perhaps we
do need more information in in terms of
the different planning committees and
how they make the decisions and and
which ones have gone to appeal so the
points that councillor stevens and
councillors edwards make
and i think that yeah this is something
that we need to think about it's
something that we need to think about
very very carefully
and if i think if with more analysis and
more information
therefore we can come back to this
and perhaps next year look at this again
present more information to members so
my proposal my recommendation
is that we withdraw this from the
meeting tonight for further analysis for
further information to come to members
so that it can come back to
council next year
and that's my recommendation
thank you now i i have to say that we've
already had a proposal by councillor
white and that is to keep things
as they are and that was seconded by
councillor none now councillor white do
you want to stand by that
okay are you happy to for that to stay
cancer done
okay okay that's fine council lagging
you wanted to say something you're
unspoken
right okay so the proposal then is by
councillor white seconded by councillor
keys uh to keep things as they are with
the with the local committees
um could i have a show of hands on that
please members
that seconded
recorded vote certainly
when you're ready um tara please call
the role
oh hang on a sec
counselor edwards
the proposal by councillor white is uh
that we keep the three local committees
um
as they are and that was seconded by um
councillor keys
it comes up every few years to do away
with the individual committees okay so
this is not for not for a referral this
is for uh a straight vote keep it as
keep it as they are
right
councillor it's your profes
uh yeah so i would just like to clarify
that if uh councillor white's
recommendation goes through
this cannot come back to full council
for six months
so if the if if cancer is white his
proposal is passed
then the recommendation said so this
cannot be considered by council again
for another six months
so and it will not go back to the
corporate working governance group
yes that's correct jess councillor voice
all right
just wait for the mic there we go um
the the six-month rule
um
applies unless
a report from a committee um i'll ask mr
quells to actually read out the the
actual wording um but if a committee
report
um
brings forward a report then the
six-month rule doesn't apply
or alternatively of ten members
um
right i see
yeah i see mr crouch is nodding
yeah okay councillor siddal
this report has come from the corporate
working governance agreement does not
come from a committee
so therefore that doesn't apply
this is not a committee report it's a
corporate working governance report
which reports into full council so that
does not apply
all right
we should
now
uh uh councillor siddal is chairman of
the strategy and resources committee
um we
if if the strategy and resources
committee brings forward a motion or
recommendation
to review this inside the six months
then it can do so
i accept that this is not a report of a
committee
but a committee can
okay that is uh that is noted then okay
so we've had a uh a request for a
recorded vote and that has been seconded
uh so this is the proposal by councillor
white
to keep the three local committees
thank you tara
yes and the district planning yes
and thank you members if you could just
indicate four against rob stone when i
call your name please starting with
councillor bussinger
thank you councillor miss beale
councillor bell
councillor boyce
council mrs channer
that's great council
mais sorry could you just come around
this way for a second
thank you
yeah thank you mr chairman and thank you
councillor chana um
you did you did leave the um
debate as did uh councillor um boyce as
well
so that should be just noted thank you
okay so we'll have to remove your vote
counselor voice
only applies to planning
committees not to full council
okay could you confirm that mr crouch
in fact it's wider than that
the
it's all regulatory matters and this
isn't a regulatory matter it's a policy
issue so
um
that is right if council mrs channel
would like to vote she can but if you
haven't heard all the if you haven't
heard all the debate in a planning
matter or a licensing matter
or any other regulatory matter then you
must not vote but in policy matters
that rule does not apply now it may well
be that a member feels it's right not to
vote if they haven't heard or the debate
but there's no constitutional
restriction on them
okay we're just okay
i will be happier having not heard all
the comments because i was out for a
little while i will uh not vote chairman
so you're
so counselor voices
vote will stand counselling now
okay
and
i think we will yes tara
thank you chairman okay members uh so
starting again councillor bassinger four
against rob stain please
thank you councillor miss beale
councillor beer castle bell
thank you cancer boyce
council mrs chennai says she's not
voting cancer durham
councillor edwards yes
councillor heard
olive stone
councillor hull
councillor keys
councillor lagan
councillor mays
councillor morley
councillor morris
councillor nunn
councillor siddall
councillor stamp
councillor stevens
councillor stilts
councillor swain
council mrs thompson
councillor miss white
chairman the results of that are 13 4 7
against one abstention thank you
chairman
thank you so that is carried
right well i think that's
so the recommendations we don't need to
do
okay
okay members thank you very much for
that we'll move on to agenda item
14
ceiling of documents
and the report on the procedure for that
leader thank you chairman um pretty
straightforward the purpose of the
report is to change the procedure for
the stealing of documents the
recommendation is that paragraph 3.1.2
of the responsibility and functions
general provisions document that forms a
part of the constitution be amended to
require only one employee to sign
whenever any document needs to be sealed
and i'd like to make that proposal do i
have a second down
councillor mays
any member wish to speak on this uh i
think councillor chana and then durham
oh gosh i'm pulling my glasses off now
thank you chairman um
i'm not going to appear critical here or
anything but actually i do have concerns
about um i i can see where the officers
may be coming from in saying that there
shouldn't be two it's quite clear
previously we have had to direct a level
legal or indeed someone of a managerial
level that reports to a director the
recommendation only states about one
employee it doesn't define the status of
that employee which i think is very very
um
worrying in terms of i could be what are
we saying any employee and i don't mean
any derogatory comments about people
that aren't in managerial positions or
director but that did concern me
i to help the officers out from what
they're saying it's causing a difficulty
with two being available
i feel chairman in the past we used to
have members involved in the sealing of
the documents
as well and i think that would take the
pressure off the officer argument
they're saying that the two is difficult
at times and hence one and therefore
chairman i would propose that we do have
one employee either director legal or in
a managerial position who reports to a
director and i would propose chairman
that it either be the leader or the
deputy leader or a committee chairman
involved in the ceiling as well and i
think that gives an ample opportunity
across the the membership to be able to
involve um chairman to do with the
ceiling so i'm advocating to one officer
director legal or manager that reports
to a director and either leader deputy
leader or committee chairman to be
involved in the ceiling as well thank
you chairman thank you casa cena it does
it does saying 3.1
that it'd be two senior employees and
then it speaks about
who they may be so it does say that
there
counselor durham you wish to speak
oh thank you
chairman it you know it's absolutely
essential that
that all
legally binding decisions
uh are safeguarded
and we as the elected uh
representatives
we are the people with responsibility to
the district residents
i've in my time i've been called to to
counter sign many many
ceilings and i think it's
it's ill-advised
that
there isn't a member
signature to counter sign against that
of a senior
there's nothing against the officers or
the directors at all but i just think
from their own point of view
it would be much better that an elected
representative
counter-signs these key decisions and
these are the most
the most important decisions that are
recorded uh so i am very happy to
support councillor channel's proposal
that it could be the leader the deputy
leader or a committee chair
um all of whom should be readily
available when things return back to
normal to just put their moniker against
a a seal thank you
thank you very much i'll go to mr quelch
for advice
perhaps there's a misunderstanding here
about the sealing process
the the sealing process is simply that
two people witness
at the moment to senior employees
witness
that the seal is being applied to a
document they are not approving that
document they are not reading that
document and in many cases do not even
know what that document is it is purely
a technical legal requirement that a
seal is applied
and increasingly
more and more authorities namely for
example essex county council all the big
authorities only have one employee
normally a solicitor um and more and
more authorities are going in the
opposite direction of what
is being proposed to one employee simply
because it is a technical
legal process it is not the examination
of the documents it is purely witnessing
the seal being applied to a piece of
paper that is what the process is
chairman thank you very much mr crouch
uh councillor boyce just next door
amazing
thank you um i i can support um mr
quelch's um explanation
the council actually used to
have the chairman of the council
nominated to sign all these documents
with the chief executive
but the council some two or three years
ago i think
uh in its wisdom decided that
it was only necessary for
a senior of two senior officers um to
sign it as i understand this report it
is now just for one officer
um
which i think perhaps is a step too far
i think it it i think it should be one
of the three
directors or
plus perhaps
legal but mr quelch is perfectly right
you are not
um
uh
signing approval of the document you're
just saying i witnessed that seal being
applied yeah and then you sign the seal
register and if you look in the sale
register as
councillor durham has said you'll find
my signature in there thousands of times
yeah okay and council channel very
briefly please
well chairman um i hear what mr quelcher
says and councillor boyce but i've been
involved in but i do recall on some
things like 106 agreements or some plans
i had to i was asked by the officers to
look at the numbers and make sure they
married with what was going in the book
and everything before my signature was
applied and i did on occasions asked
exactly what i was seeing
so i did have an understanding not in
great depth but just so i felt
comfortable signing a particularly legal
agreement that was binding the council
thank you
thank you okay members so this is merely
uh the ceiling of the documents and it
is the procedure
that follows
um
so i have i have had a proposal
uh that uh it includes the leader and
deputy leader or the or the chairman i
think that was by yourself counselor
channel wasn't it
sorry um i did say um
uh leader deputy leader or committee
chairman it could be the chairman of the
council as well i i'm i'm applying those
sort of people in those positions
chairman and i think that would actually
they should be available has been
highlighted um when we sort of get more
back to normal and of course an officer
of the required um level as well i think
it does need to be director i know you
mentioned chairman about senior level
but it that to me should be reflected by
director legal or manager who reports to
a director because the recommendation
only refers to one employee thank you
thank you do i do i have a seconder for
that proposal
councillor durham okay in that case
members i will put it to the vote
uh those in favor of councillor chana's
proposal of including
either the leader deputy leader chairman
or vice chairman
um
please could they indicate if they agree
could i have you clearly a hands up
please could we just count count those
all right it's cool yeah we'll call the
names out okay
just please say for or against
uh councillor bussinger
thank you
councillor miss beale
councillor bell
councillor boyce
council mrs channer
councillor durham
councillor edwards
councillor herd against
councillor hull
councillor keys
councillor lagan
councillor mays
councillor morley councillor morris
councillor nunn
councillor siddall
councillor stamp
councillor stevens
councillor stilts
councillor swain
council mrs thompson
councillor miss white
chairman that's 11 4 9 against two
abstentions thank you
that is carrie then in that case
right okay
we move on now to questions to the
leader of the council in accordance with
procedure rule one three i see
councillor siddal and councillor swain
councillor siddl first at the back
and councillor morris
uh thank you chairman uh over the past
year the council has faced the challenge
of covid
after having gone through the recent
transformation
having read the report that was
presented to over overview and scrutiny
on the transformation
how does the leader feel the in
independent administration has faced
those challenges
and at the same time supported staff and
services
thank you so
much thank you councillor siddall
excellent question
um i think we have handled it to the
best of
our ability i think the staff the
officers have been
superb it's been very difficult
obviously
the transformation and the cuts that
this council has had to
deal with
has caused us some issues and still will
cause us some issues due to the lack of
staff
and
people on the ground actually cancer
citadel um but i for one am very proud
of this council i'm very proud that the
majority of people seem to work together
for the benefit of the council and
that's from all parties and all sides
and i think the majority of us do do the
best of what we can to help our
residents within difficult circumstances
so i actually think we're doing very
well not everybody will agree obviously
councillor siddal but i think the
majority will and the directors and the
staff
are working very very hard under the
difficult circumstances and pressures
that they've all been put under thank
you
thank you very much councillor swain
thank you chairman yes i want to put
this to the leader
whilst many people enjoyed the events of
the weekends of 24th 5th july and 1st
2nd of august in promenade park
for many local residents the noise level
was excessive and intrusive
residential streets were jammed with
visitors cars blocking their accesses
while others blocked pavements to
mobility scooters and push chairs to
which was added noise and disruption
when the arena was set up and
particularly when being dismantled in
the early hours of monday the first
third
how can these problems be avoided or
mitigated in future please
thank you
um thank you
thank you councillor swain um the i'm
going to um go to uh
um forgot his name mr holmes in a moment
because
we have had some complaints we've also
had many many people say what fantastic
uh
function and weekend it was uh two
weekends of entertainment um i it is my
understanding and i'll be corrected if
i'm wrong there is still a wash up
meeting and there's still information to
be collected to make sure that if the
events go on next year that we can
actually address some of the urgent
concerns and they were urgent concerns
because it did affect some residents and
everybody's opinion is valuable
but like i said the worship meeting
hasn't taken place mr
holmes can you help me on that i could
be wrong but i think it's taking place
next week or this week
i think it's just behind you thank you
uh yes absolutely the events were a
pilot event um obviously we were looking
at how to run these larger events in
town lots of mitigation was put in place
uh but there were a number of issues
that we obviously identified and council
swain has mentioned some of those this
evening so there is an officer review
meeting and we will be meeting with the
promoter and obviously the issues that
uh we discovered um would be taken into
account in any decision to hold that
event again or an event like that again
in the town and as the leader has said
those meetings start next week
okay
thank you okay council morris
thank you mr chairman um just i've got
three questions for the leader
um the first one was that uh you
contacted me on the 29th of january and
um it was concerning a gentleman called
gary deuce
did you ever use your position at this
council to cause him and his business
any problems
the second question
what is
why did you ask me to put stuff on
facebook about counselor voice when you
have your own social media and finally
do you still think that counselor heard
is an idiot and a melt
if anyone would like background to any
of these questions
have a look at my facebook and members
i've emailed you all the relevant
items
counselor stamp
um we'll see oh councillor morris yes i
do apologize i keep forgetting things at
the moment
um i'm not going to be drawn into any of
your
um
what's the word
comments trying to disgrace yet another
leader um um it is very sad i'm afraid
that because no
please don't interrupt we list are you
going to listen to me counselor morris i
gave you the um respect to you're not
you're interrupting me
chairman i i'm not prepared to carry on
you've uh you've you've asked your
question uh i'm you've asked three
questions uh the leader has the
opportunity to give you a written
response to those if she wishes
so i'm going to move on does anybody
else have any other questions
counselor channel
sorry are we moving on chairman or
yes i'm asking you cancer channel oh
thank you thank you chairman um could i
please um can i ask the leader um can
she advise what conversations or
discussions that perhaps she has been
involved in um regarding county deals
bearing in mind the fairly recent
correspondence and that she would have
received i'm sorry councillor
i can hardly hear you oh okay sorry i
thought the mic was here right okay
chairman i perhaps i've got to get quite
close to it
um yes can the leader advise what
conversations discussions
uh if she can she has perhaps been
involved in
regarding county deals bearing in mind
the recent correspondence that she would
have received and which
may affect not only this council but
those in essex and of course uh the
wider world country i do have another
question as well chairman if i may but
that's the first one thank you
right okay could you be specific about
what county deals you mean
the one the correspondents referred to
the government has said about county
deals
in terms of working districts and
counties together i mean there is
correspondence from it that came from i
believe government
um i can't answer
cancer channel i can't answer that
question and we'll get back to you
according to rule six five because i i
honestly don't know what you're talking
about i don't know if mr dodson can help
me or assist me on that if it hasn't
come to me um obviously counselor durham
can because he's put his hand up so he
might be able to answer it
organisation might be another word and
but it's termed county deals
no okay i think i think if that question
is submitted to the leader she will
respond in writing
what's your second question please um
chairman um the second question is
obviously um recently um
and i'm it's admirable all the work the
officers did to get the splash park
operating
um but recently um as we know due to
unfortunate happenings in regarding
staff
um the officers um we have had to close
it and obviously we can't open it again
could the leader perhaps give an
indication because it did refer to uh
the articles i've read about refunds and
i've been asked
about this can the leader give an
indication in terms of the refunds um
what sort of amount of money that might
be or the numbers involved and is there
a refund policy criteria thing um thank
be very helpful chairman if um the
leader may have any information on that
thank you
thank you councillor chana we've asked
for that information it's going to be
produced by one of the directors
hopefully within the next few days
because we are aware of the refunds
i think there has been some technical
issues regarding that and we're just
waiting an update from the directors so
i can give you a written report on that
when i get it but it has been asked for
councillor china thank you thank you
very much councillor durham now please
thank you chairman i i will re-ask
councillor chana's uh question of the
leader and remind the leader that she
received from the leader of essex county
council a full summary of the mhclg
proposal for local government reform in
the form of county deals
also the leader of braintree rochford
castle point and chelmsford city council
saw fit to provide all of their members
the same briefing to keep them appraised
of the potential
future for local government but members
of this authority have not been
appraised chairman and i just wonder if
the leader could let us know when she
plans to advise the membership of malden
district council about the government's
proposals for local government
reorganization thank you before you
answer that leader
i think she has already explained that
if councillor
chana submits that as a written question
she will reply give a written reply but
i'll hand over to the leader um thank
you um councillor durham i think i've
already as councillor heard has just
said
i i am not fully aware of the
information it maybe has come across my
desk it maybe is being dealt with at the
moment but i don't know i don't know if
paul dodson can actually jump in
and
give an answer on this at the moment
because i can't i'm not going to lie i'm
not going to sit here and lie and make
some something up members just to try
just sorry
carry on carry on
chairman i'm finding it really difficult
i'm being stared constantly out by a
counsellor when i'm trying to conduct
cancelled business here i'm finding it
intimidating and i find it threatening
i'm so sorry i'm talking about you
councillor morris
i'm sorry right
okay
right i am i am going to bring this
to a close now we have been 11 minutes i
think the time is 21.41
and uh i'm going to go to agenda item 16
which is any other items of business
that the chairman of the committee
decides are urgent i do have one
this is to review and appoint a
representative to the river crouch
coastal community team steering group
uh who is going to present this report
later
thank you councillor morris leader
councilman
thank you
as councillor china which does she wish
to speak before i present this report
did you wish to speak counselor jana
no i've moved on from that i'm sorry if
you if you have if you wish to put your
question in writing to the leader please
do that
the question
and
sorry i believe i asked the question and
the leader said she'd give him a
response i don't think uh well i'm i'm
pretty sure i know you're saying i've
got to put that in writing but i've
asked the question verbally it's on
record and i believe the leader said
she'd give a written answer
that is correct but you said i've got to
give a have a written question i don't
believe that i need to chairman
with due respect
yes you don't have to write in the
question no
thank you okay so we'll move on to um
agenda item
19. i'm just getting the papers up
yes 16 urgent items yes sorry i've just
lost the page here sorry
lee done okay thank you chairman um this
is an urgent item of business that has
been added late on to the agenda members
it's the appointment to the river crouch
coastal community team steering group
the purpose of the report is to review
and appoint one representative to the
river crouch coastal community team
steering group
this matter is brought forward for
consideration with the agreement of the
chairman which is what i've just said
and needs to be confirmed before the
steering group meeting on the 14th of
september 2021.
um the recommendation is that the
council appoint one representative to
the river crotch coastal community team
steering group for the remainder of the
municipal year i would like to make that
proposal and i would like to propose uh
councillor mark bassinger to actually be
appointed to that committee is that
seconded
it is can we
agree that members
agreed councillor channel
i did have my hand up very early
i would like to say that councillor anne
hull has lived in burnham for a very
long time
she has knowledge of the river crouch
she's part of the farming community as
well which obviously
encompasses the coastal matters
as well so i would like to propose
councillor anne hull to be on that body
as the council's representative thank
you chairman
and that is seconded okay
so we have a proposal first of all for
councillor bassinger
and can we have a recorded is that
seconded
seconded so we'll have a recorded vote
if
should that be should that fail
uh then we'll move on to to the second
one so
could you call the role please tara
this is for council of messenger
yes kevin uh so starting with councillor
bassinger if you could indicate four
against or abstain please
councillor miss beale
councillor bell
councillor boyce is gone councilman says
chana
councillor durham
councillor edwards
councillor heard for
councillor hull
councillor keys
councillor lagan
catherine reyes
councillor morley
councillor morris
councillor none
councillor siddall
councillor stamp
councillor stevens
council mrs stilts
councillor swain
council mrs thompson
that's miss white
chairman that's 13 4 8 against no
abstentions thank you that's uh in that
case that's carried councillor passenger
thank you very much
i now move on to agenda item 17
exclusion of the public and press we
move to item
this item to resolve that under section
104 of the local government act
yes council
uh thank you chairman sorry for
interrupting uh so uh councillor boyce
has now left the meeting
so therefore we didn't actually move the
recommendations for the strategy
resources committee so therefore i'd
like to move that we accept the
recommendations for the strategy
resources committee can i have a second
to please
can we agree that
thank you
that is agreed then thank you very much
so uh we moved to uh to agenda item
seven
yes councillor swain
sorry the second item on the supplement
to a supplementary agenda
um relating some updates on the taxi and
private hire policy
do we assume that that's been
agreed in the course of the previous
decision he was agreed yes
yeah
okay
right okay so we moved to
resolve that under section 100a of the
local government act 1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for the following of items of business
on the grounds that they involve the
likely disclosure of exempt information
as described in paragraph
12 a part 1 of the schedule 12a of the
act and this satisfies the public
interest test do i have a seconder
thank you councillor mays so at this
stage we say goodbye to members of the
public
is it all agreed
thank you tara can we confirm that the
livestream has been turned off before we
move
you